vamos a realizar algunas prácticas para
evaluar expresiones cuando tienen dos
diferentes variables veamos si podemos
evaluar la expresión 7 j
+ 5 menos 8 k cuando jota es igual a 0.5
y k es igual a 0.25 los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de evaluar
esto por su cuenta antes de que veamos
la solución juntos aquí para evaluar
esta expresión tendremos que reemplazar
cada jota que encontremos con este valor
de aquí y lo mismo con cada acá que nos
encontremos la vamos a reemplazar con
0.25 vamos a hacerlo esto será 7 que
multiplica a jota pero jota quedamos que
vale 0.5 así que nos queda 7 por jota
pero reemplazamos por 0.5
después sigue
más 5 menos 8 por acá pero vamos a
reemplazar cada por su valor que es de
0.25
así que multiplicamos 8 por 0.25 y que
va a ser esto bueno tengo esto de aquí
que es 7 por punto 5 bueno 7 por punto 5
va a ser igual a 3.5 le sigue a esto más
5 y ahora voy a restar esto de 8 por
punto 25 esto de 0.25 es lo mismo que un
cuarto esto yo lo puedo reescribir si yo
quisiera como
un cuarto ocho por un cuarto o lo que es
lo mismo ocho dividido entre cuatro va a
ser igual a dos así que todo esto de
aquí es dos y tenemos este menos que lo
ponemos aquí menos dos y esto que va a
ser bueno 3.55 va a ser igual a 8.5 8.5
menos 2 va a ser igual a 6.5 6.5 así que
esto es igual a esto y esto es igual a
6.5 hagamos otro problema y nuevamente
tratan de resolver esto por su cuenta
antes de ver cómo lo resolvemos aquí
bueno vamos a resolverlo juntos por aquí
tenemos esta expresión 0.1 por m más 8
menos 12 por n
cuando m es igual a 30 m es igual a un
cuarto así que en cada lugar que yo me
encuentre una m
lo voy a reemplazar por este 32
me encuentre una n lo voy a reemplazar
por un cuarto
bueno entonces tenemos que es 0.1 por m
me quedamos que es 30 esto es por 30 más
8 - 12 por n estã n quedamos que es un
cuarto 12 por un cuarto veamos cuánto es
un décimo por 30 es de 0.1 es un décimo
por 30 nos va a dar 3 así que aquí
tenemos 3 luego tenemos más 8 menos 12
por un cuarto cuánto va a ser 12 por un
cuarto o 12 entre 4 pues va a ser igual
a 3
ahora evaluamos esto esto es igual a
esto tres menos tres pues se van a
cancelar este 3 positivo se cancela con
ese 3 negativo y lo que me queda es este
8 así que esto es igual a 8 y con esto
terminamos esta expresión cuando m es
igual a 30 y en es igual a un cuarto va
a ser igual a 8